和姐妹啊，
都在聊卖淫这个话题吧，
我还是希望我自己的粉丝，
我们作为成熟的理性的观众，
我们不要去人家的那个账号上去宣泄一种情绪和愤怒，
不要谩骂，
也不要人身攻击，
我们就是说通过麦灵我们可以观察到自己，
其实我跟大家讲实话，
我大概20多岁的时候，
其实有一点像麦灵，
像麦灵的哪个点呢？
就是在任何一个社交场合，
总是希望自己能够说出，
总是希望别人能够注意到自己，
总是希望自己和别人能够平起平坐的去聊很多的话题，
所以在很多聚会的场合，
或者说什么论坛的场合的话，
就是在很努力的去表现的，
自己跟别人是平等的，
自己跟别人的有话题可聊的。
其实我看到呃，
麦琳在和杨紫和刘一手，
他们彻夜长谈的那个画面的时候，
我就回想了二十几岁的时候的我自己，
那个时候就心里面特别渴望得到别人的认可尊重，
特别渴望别人觉得我也是很有能力的，
特别渴望别人觉得我跟他是平等的，
但是现在回过头去看我二十几岁的状态的话，
其实是跟麦林很像的，
但是从因为你们知道。
我是干律师的，
那么我接触的有很多都是大老板啊，
企业家啊什么的，
其实从人家那些大老板和企业家的角度来看我的话，
就会觉得我像一个嗯，
太急于表现自己的一个小破孩儿，
就小屁孩儿的那种状态，
他们内心深处对我是没有尊重的，
是没有那种说我跟人家是平起平坐的这样一个关系的，
昨天的时候可能也是一种礼貌或者敷衍，
大家能想象得到那样的场景吗？
后来是大概在我30来岁的时候，
就是当我的专业能力，
我的律师这方面的专业能力到达了一定娴熟的水平了，
那个时候我在社交场合的时候，
在跟别人聊天，
可能人家会通过认可我的专业能力，
对我这样一个律师或者女性会有一份尊重和认可在，
但是当我自己没有这个专业能力在的时候，
我却寄希望于别人把我当成一个很重要的人，
把我当成一个好像跟人家有共同话题的人去聊的时候，
其实那个时候我自己的那个状态就是拧巴的，
就是在别人看来是可笑的状态，
我就是想通过自我的剖析，
想跟我的粉丝去聊一种状态，
就是我们看到任何一个人的时候，
我们先不要去攻击他，
不要去谩骂他，
我们把他当成一面镜子来照射自己，
包括像我看到杨紫，
我也会像照镜子一样，
看到自己的很多状态，
就是比如说人家没有问我的人生履历的时候，
我也有过那种状态，
说特别想要聊聊自己的战绩，
聊聊自己的成绩，
聊聊自己当年有多优秀，
当年有多厉害，
那这一瞬间的话，
其实我也是杨紫，
我不知道大家能不能get到龙飞姐想表达的这个意思，
就是我们看到任何一个人的时候。
先不要骂，
先不要攻击，
先不要去啊，
带着恶意去，
呃，
批评别人，
就是先把它当成一面镜子来照一下我们自己身上的问题啊，
就这意思啊。